today for our daily cancellation we
finally have a chance to cancel jen
pasaki she has teetered close a few
times swerving precariously near the
edge of being canceled but now she's
finally gone over the cliff and uh she
needed some help from vogue magazine to
get there
in an especially glowing and sycophantic
profile of pasaki one which would have
induced nausea in me if not for my
trusty relief band the writer lizzie
whittycomb which is somehow the perfect
name for a vogue writer lizzie wittycomb
tells us quote obama world was famously
famously harsh with the press
we'll take a side note right after one
sentence yeah we all remember the
famously contentious relationship
between obama and the press i mean the
same press that spent two weeks talking
about obama's tan suit while he was
sending drones out to assassinate
american citizens
anyway it says
pasaki recalls of the obama people
they're my friends and they're some of
the absolute the most talented and best
people i worked with in politics but the
culture was to yell at reporters slam
the phone down after traveling with
journalists for weeks on end
and in many cases bonding with them
pasaki realized that's never going to be
comfortable to me instead she developed
a more personable report charming her
interlocutors with little jokes asking
about their hometowns and families she's
not a pushover though at one point she
tells me that she hates when people
describe her as nice
she says quote it's like nails on a
chalkboard and it still happens i was
introduced to a foreign delegation in
the hallway the other day as this is jen
you may have seen her do the briefing
she's a really nice person i'm like
really you can't think of a better
description
the word is sexist and a little
diminishing but she says it's also this
desire to put people in a box yes
sometimes i'm friendly and joyful and
sometimes i'm tough and sometimes i'm
straightforward
now you have to appreciate how there's
no attempt at an explanation here it
simply asserted that the word nice which
is last i checked the compliment
is not only sexist but diminishing
it's assumed that the reader will
understand how and why this is the case
and no further details are required now
i admit that
i may be a little out of my depth with
this discussion because i have so little
experience with being called nice um if
i was called nice i may actually take it
as an insult but only because i'd assume
that the description was sarcastic like
oh there's matt he's a real nice guy
kind of like the one and only time in my
life when i participated in singing the
happy birthday song to someone
and afterwards a person standing next to
me turned and said wow great singing
voice matt
and walked away laughing
well i ran and locked myself in the
bathroom and wept for hours the whole
scene really ruined my son's birthday
but this is all beside the point how can
a word like nice be considered not only
insulting but sexist
you know i think there are two potential
answers well three
because the first answer is just that
everything is stupid and everyone is
stupid and our culture is a cyclone of
stupid leveling everything in its path
but more specifically uh here are two
other points worth considering first
as we've covered extensively on this
show
in the words of philip reeve we live in
the age of psychological man and all
that matters in our age indeed the only
true reality in our age is how a person
feels about themselves
when the perspective of the individual
self fully immersed in the spirit of the
age the job of everyone else is to
affirm those feelings
and in fact it goes one level deeper
than that and it's more schizophrenic
than that
because your job as an outsider in
relation to me
it's not so much to affirm how i feel
about myself
but to affirm how i want to feel about
myself
after all i might feel like an ugly lump
of moldy lard but i want to feel
strong and brave and stunning and
beautiful those are the feelings i'm
trying to desperately to engender within
myself
your job is to somehow identify how i
want to feel
which may or may not be how i actually
feel and affirm it as a reality
my self-actualization to use the new age
jargon is your project
by simply coming in contact with me you
have been thrust into my own internal
drama and you now play a central role
whether you want to or not how does this
relate to jen pasake well
she wants to feel like a tough person at
least sometimes
if you encounter her in one of those
moments where she wants to be as she
says tough and straightforward and you
make the mistake of describing her in a
way that conflicts with that desire then
you are attacking her you're diminishing
her
if it sounds like we're at a point where
you simply can't describe another person
or even refer to them without
potentially causing devastating
psychological harm that's correct i mean
that's where we're at
to say anything about another human
being even to refer to them in a neutral
but grammatically correct way is to
potentially undermine the feelings they
want to feel about themselves
and those feelings and desires can
change by the minute especially for
women
no offense which makes the whole thing a
minefield
the second point um is the familiar
irony
that jen pasaki is a feminist
and feminists hate men
but idolize them at the same time
i mean what's wrong with being nice well
because jen pasake associates niceness
with women and toughness with men
and she would rather be seen as having
manly qualities because she has decided
that manly qualities are superior
this is what makes female bosses and
managers sometimes so miserable to work
for i mean men can be real jerks too of
course and bad bosses but
females in positions of authority are
more likely to want to be seen as jerks
they're more likely to overcompensate
rejecting their nicer instincts in this
effort to approximate the manliness that
they idolize
so it's a twisted picture really
feminists
worship masculinity
but rather than simply appreciating men
and being grateful for them
these people who harbor masculinity
they would rather take the place of men
becoming pale imitations of the thing
they admire
i mean ultimately destroying the very
thing that they admire
and you see it on the other side too you
see men
who worship femininity
but rather than appreciating women and
being grateful for them they try to
literally transform into women and take
their place
once again destroying the very thing
that they idolize so it's quite a
confused picture creates a cultural
environment that is
well not very nice to live in so maybe
jen posaki gets her wish in the end even
so she is still today we must say
cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated